is Christian Wilkins underrated you
gotta change the route no heck no come
on
going up for it oh
[Music]
welcome to underrated the only show
where professional athletes can improve
their video game ratings you see that
athletic specimen behind me that is the
anchor of the Miami defense Christian
Wilkins we're bumping ratings
[Music]
[Applause]
you've caught a touchdown two years ago
then you caught a touchdown and then you
did the worm last year from Tua which I
thought was as impressive as the
touchdown appreciate it what does it
feel like to catch a touchdown it's nice
uh it's a lot of fun you got to kind of
keep your composure a little bit in the
Huddle you don't want to give anything
up to the to the defense or like hype
yourself with too much smiling exactly
it's just like hey so you got to kind of
make it smaller like just act like
you're in the backyard playing football
because you have two catches and two
touchdowns
and two yards we believe that your
Madden rating needs to go up do you
agree with me I I definitely agree okay
I have the plug and we're gonna handle
this today all right Clint get out here
foreign
Oldenburg Madden ratings performance
adjuster I am between two huge humans
right now what we're going to work on
today is your route running okay and
your spectacular catches what's your
rating for Route running not very good I
would say somewhere in this
he said which means 30s or 30 40s so
where is it actually self-aware so short
route running you're 31. okay that puts
you 17th among all defensive ends in the
NFL okay okay what about spectacular
catches again same same kind of deal
42 spec catch okay and the twos you know
where he ranked 22nd can we bump them up
today with good performances I think
that's for him to answer okay I like it
you better get that clipboard because
it's Christian Wilkins time let's go
baby
all right Christian we are in your zone
right by the goal line two catches two
yards two touchdowns simple flat catch
let's just show them what you got man
let's do it
[Music]
whenever you're ready pal
[Music]
easy work oh a little celebration oh
into the worm into the worm oh Adam pose
wow
I'm a big supporter of big guys scoring
touchdowns and doing the work
[Music]
I don't even care if you're sweating
let's go that was amazing I appreciate
it how amazing was that it was not bad
but we've seen it before I mean he has
done it twice that's fair okay so then
what do you need to see are there any
Defenders NFL defensive players in the
area
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
yes there is one of the best corners in
the NFL AJ Terrell I think you guys have
a history we do Clemson national
champions uh-huh that's right have he
ever guarded you before he is not is
this something you've dreamed about
um absolutely I always talk a little
Trash thing he's ever guarded a player
like me which is true which is probably
true so this is the first time but this
is the first time but he's a heck of a
player and I want to want to test my
skills we're going for spectacular catch
is this good enough for you and Route
running and Route okay we're getting
Madden ratings up all right AJ you got
out there you're doing man coverage we
need to work on your route running all
right how you're going to get open right
here what do we thinking
this is this has always been a dream of
my goal line yeah let's have a big man
stream jump off fade back the end zone
Jim Lafayette he's gonna try to press me
okay so I'm gonna give him a little
wiggle okay at the line scrimmage just
throw it up so you're literally gonna
read the defense you gotta read the
defender
you have to give us a helmet all right
yes so we're gonna jump off it first
okay all right all right
and break hey so now what is her his
rating if I if I catch this on him we
hadn't thought of that it's on it's on
it's on all right Wilkins is on the line
ref I'm good
he's good no tap
that's a push off he's calling for OPI I
didn't see it and I know my boy full
extensions
played at the pilot yeah but he did run
a nice round he did very nice it was
push-off though I didn't know how hard
he was going to garbage right now do you
want to do a different route the same
route same route
come on we're good
AJ's really in a stance right now
Wilkins stutter going up for it oh
all right so it's one one
come on we gotta do one more break the
time we gotta do one more one more for
the tie breaker you gotta change the
route yep no heck no come on
hey breath
he's going for it again
AJ knows what route's coming
[Music]
he wasn't ready for it
[Music]
shout out to Jay a little spit hey
get money cigarette
get over here both of you guys
first of all I didn't see the helmet tap
yeah but he was ready for the for the
Fate he hit him with the Slants how good
did it feel it felt great I actually
felt legit right there I felt like a
true receiver it's fun getting out there
doing a little Razzle down so it was
nice you have covered some of the best
receivers you have also played with this
guy for a number of years what did you
think of his route running it was good
good for a bit man yeah good for a big
manner good good for a big man okay yeah
good for a beat man Christian Gronkowski
Moss Wilkins that's my those are my
middle names yeah uh it's good that a
competitor and a former teammate likes
it but we need to get to our Madden
ratings performance adjuster what do we
think route running spec catch your your
take well the thing is six ounce the
route running and that slant especially
was really smooth he said he felt it and
he made the stick he cut and he didn't
watch the ball into his hands he looked
like a receiver so short route running
he was at 31. he's going up seven points
from a 31 to a 38.
all that being said this is the question
Clint is Christian Wilkins underrated
Christian Wilkins is definitely
underrated he said definitely sir how do
you feel about that I'm I'm pretty
excited about that I'll take the jump
again I think it's a little lower than
what it should be but I'm happy with the
Improvement I just want to be able to
prove myself each and every year
congratulations Christian Wilkins is
underrated baby
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]